[Musique]
alors que jean castex a annoncé hier les
mesures concernant les prochaines
semaines avec notamment la restriction
de six adultes à table lors du réveillon
de noël et un couvre feu le soir du 31
décembre rester chez soi donc le 31
décembre
aujourd'hui les questions se posent
quant aux solutions pour s'assurer du
respect de ces règles
car s'il est possible pour les policiers
de veiller au respect du couvre-feu les
forces de l'ordre n'ont pas de moyen de
rentrer chez les gens pour vérifier
s'ils respectent le nombre limité de
convives à quelqu'un pourtant très
proche de nous en belgique les contrôles
sont beaucoup plus poussée là bas les
policiers ont le droit d'entrer au
domicile de particuliers sous certaines
conditions
avec l'accord du propriétaire ou s'il ya
de sérieuses indications que les règles
ne soient pas respectées il faut pas
choquant dans la province de lyme pour
la police locale a même décidé de
déployer pour les fêtes des drones
thermique qui permet de détecter la
présence d'individus même à l'intérieur
d'une habitation
elles sont capables de détecter une
présence humaine la nuit y compris à
l'intérieur de bâtiments des solutions
qui paraissent extrême et qui sont
motivés par l'intérêt commun et la
volonté de stopper le virus alors soirée
du nouvel an faut-il autoriser les
policiers d'entrer chez les gens mais
non de toute façon à moins de détenir un
mandat personne n'a le droit de rentrer
chez fric ou pas il ya un article et
200m 6-4 si jamais quelqu'un s'est
introduit chez mais je t'ai huissier non
c'est interdit de rentrer chez vous
c'est formellement interdit bien sûr il
faut demander la permission maintenant
vous êtes a dû au mandat d'arrêt non moi
de détenir un mandat les flics n'ont pas
le droit de rentrer chez vous mais ils
vont chez un adulte je termine ta mère
sait jamais si jamais vous autorisé
jeudi la grand mère il change alors
général si vous vous autorisez vous êtes
adulte au ficg de rentrer chez vous qui
peuvent rentrer notamment via l'article
226-1 capella du code pénal que si
quelques s'introduit chez vous contre
votre volonté ses cent cinquante mille
euros d'amendé
on peut mettre une amende aux flics
banner et ça peut aller jeter un an
d'emprisonnement 46 c'est nicolas permis
son nom bernis book d'alcool si la vidéo
est là on parle la belgique donc c'est
pas du tout les mêmes règlements s'en
fout la belgique prenne on adore la
belgique mais là vous avez pris
l'exemple de la belgique c'est mes potes
mais moi aussi c'est citoyen d'honneur
de la ville de lezennes tu vas
comprendre
d'ailleurs c'est simple accord du roi
qu'on a droit de rentrer chez lui en
belgique mais en france on essaye
d'éviter à troisième vague donc un
moment donné il faut jouer le jeu vous
avez bien vu on en a parlé il ya
quelques semaines il ya des gens qui
font des fêtes avec 300 personnes où la
police ne peut même pas rentrer ne peut
même pas arrêter la fête sont les
clusters donc vous parler à une jennifer
qui a eu le coc vide et qui a
aujourd'hui d'effets secondaires
aujourd'hui il faut absolument qu'on
arrête cette pandémie ce qu'ils peuvent
est ce qu'ils savent faire un arrêté
pour dire qu'on a le droit de rentrer ça
normal si vous avez jamais sans leur 400
jeunes ont dit ce qu'ils soient dans
celle à qui veut intervenir sinon ils
auront droit de venir devant la maison
et de mettre une amende de sanctionner
les personnes en étant à l'extérieur
oui peuvent vous mettre une amende donc
décret du 29 octobre 2020 ou l'eau donc
si on parle de choses sérieuses
ils pourront vous m 135 euros damende
s'il ya une fête privée et il n'y a pas
la distanciation et en plus vous pouvez
être dénoncés pour tapage nocturne 68
euros l'amande donc si vous voulez
fermer fait les jeunes les i puisque moi
ça me choque de voir tous ces tweets
décomplexée de jeunes qui se disent oui
on s'en fout on écoute la castex on va
aller faire la fête
non effectivement je rejoins nico j'ai
eu aussi ce virus j'ai eu aussi de
graves effets secondaires
donc il ne faut pas de brassage il ne
faut pas d'interaction il ne faut
surtout pas faire de fête le soir du 31
gilles voulait réagir
ouais non c'était là il parlait de la
fête de 300 personnes s'étaient joints
ville le pont d'essars terre d'argile le
pont et c'était une soirée un peu marc
dorcel voisinage abidjan et le pont j'ai
pas été invitée chez le débranchement
mais ça c'est à ça oui jean pascal je
trouve ça scandaleux que tu faisais ça
on est je pense qu' on est sur un
principe de faire confiance à 1,6 donc
oui je trouve ça scandaleux parce qu'il
faut aussi faire confiance aux gens on
met des règles essayé de respecter ça
moi les gens qui viennent chez toi ça
veut dire que ben on va garder aussi un
morceau de bûche du réveillon avec avec
les policiers je pense qu'il faut garder
la vie privée et faire confiance aussi
aux gens notre jeu parce ya une fête
privée de plusieurs personnes
rien là les mecs dans l' escalade de
l'horreur là où les policiers jean
pascal
ils vont pas taper n'importe quelle
porte ce qui se passe à new york en
tuera du nez tranquillement castrats
bonnes affaires sinon attention
alors oui alors et on peut faire du
bruit à 6 compris tout seul tout seul
dans sa maison pour moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec jean pascal
parce qu'en fait on peut faire autant de
bruit à 6k 20 et effectivement il nous
accorde six personnes mais aucune
confiance donc sauf que déjà à
l'histoire des drones c'est complètement
déplacé
et puis même je veux dire toquer à la
porte des gens pour voir si jamais on
est 6 ou 20 ou 30 ou 100 ge tarantia
rend par exemple a carrément cet hymne
c'est caricatural on parle pas de ce
type de 10 personnes 15 personnes on
parle de fêtes de 203 personnes qui sont
des clusters et un risque mais tout le
monde n'a pas de sens mais caricom
europe 1 au lendemain on le sait à
joinville le pont ils ont fait des ils
ont fait les soirs et toutes les
semaines il y avait fait il y avait la
police qui débarquait il n'arrêtait pas
y continuez continuez à leur chose qui
bat et qui va être à petit se dit la
vérité ce soir 20 noms qui va être
appliqué
alors je donnerais vos adresses série
djediat 4 au fond est ce que vous allez
faire pendant le jour de l'an avec tout
vos femmes ou seulement oui on va être
un peu plus de 6 et sucé oran font
attention ces annonces alors tu n'as pas
moins de 6 ans c'est la grand font moins
de 12 ans 12 en valeur autant je déteste
les théories complotistes qui
sous-entendent qu'à une puissance au
dessus de nous qui venons contrôler
autant la surveiller les gens avec des
drones s'incruster chez les gens rentrés
de force chez les gens souffrent ont
franchi un pas dans l'anxiogène c'est
horrible
la policière en chine enfin c'est
terrible mais là c'est à ça c'est
mélanger aurait joué deuxième truc si
vous avez de la vienne étages ça va
chier des bulles car ils l'ont dit et
j'ai des infos de ministère de
l'intérieur aux dires ils seront veneta
ou papy brossard opprimés de la
dictature là on arrive avec des
la mère les enfants c'est pour les plus
de 12 ans les 8 12 ans me font quoi en
fait à dire si on a cinq enfants qui ont
plus de 12 ans peut pas voler bas
écouter ba et ba vous mettez un enfant
malade dans les bars voulait dispatchés
dans l'immeuble maréchaux 6 1
on va dire que je vais vous montrer de
quel bois je me chauffe oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya cent mille policiers qui vont
être oui sur le territoire faisait pour
vérifier et les pauvres policiers quoi
bon les masques pour les accréditations
en fait c'est l'enfer pour eux je trouve
et moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
responsable on est tous sur le même
bateau et si on n'est pas capable sur et
on nous infantilise en permanence de se
dire on et voilà on veut absolument s'en
sortir on n'en peuvent plus de ce virus
ça gâche nos vies ça gâche tout donc
soyons un petit peu responsable préfère
quand même confiance à l'intelligence
collective
je vais reprendre le sait la métaphore
de géraldine maillet japon alors si on
est tous sur le même bateau
et si je peux vous dire qu'on veut pas
que ça se termine dans titanic
il va falloir qu'on est oui mais oui
mais j'ai regardé tout je vais y aller
ça bouffe bien mais sauf que les gens ne
comprennent pas pourquoi le virus ne
circule pas à noël et au jour de l'an
c'est le genre de la maison
on leur dit oui et pas pour longtemps
ils ont très bien compris quand il ya la
fondation par exemple ou bien alors là
on est sûr le jour de l'an parce
qu'après on aura le spécialiste la
noëlle asselain député connaît tout sur
noël nature bien qu'on peut demander
quoi que tu as dit oui s'emballe droite
sont n'a pas loin est-ce que je peux
mettre une guirlande autour du cou de ma
meuf et après de la m - non c'est parce
que si tu dis qu'est ce qu'on peut
mettre le sapin moins de dix centimètres
de nous il peut voir si ça parle fort on
accepte et on savait qu'à rome à la
basilique saint pierre ils vont faire la
messe de minuit à 17 heures non alors
pourquoi ils ont concentré à bras
faisant plus tranquille et vous faites
une de mouvaux millions c'est la
première fois qu'il a des enfants mais
c'est vrai tu fais la radio vendredi
non c'est pour ça pour ça tu es meilleur
que tu les connais très bien mais on
sait très bien que nous maintenant c'est
la fête famille c'est la fête des amis
exactement j'ai eu plein de jeunes j'ai
entendu plein de jeunes gens
rien à [ __ ] on sera plus de 50 des 60
pour ça aussi le savent aussi qu'ils se
dit que ça se dit ça bien sûr ce qui est
énervant aussi et ce qui est indécent
c'est de voir le sacrifice de tout le
monde des gens aujourd'hui qui n'ont
plus rien qui ne peuvent plus travailler
et aujourd'hui il va tout mettre à mal
pour une simple fête donc c'est
totalement égoïste de faire alors alors
nous allons donc qui qui va respecter
les règles ben moi bah oui qui va
respecter direct et bien sûr famille
gide alma nouveaux venus ne va pas
respecté moi j'ai une trop bonne vanne a
même arrêté de me casser la tête avec ça
je vous le dis la famille pas la famille
je parle à part ça pernikoff vous n'avez
pas respecté sa team non parce que
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on soit 6
avec un maître de distanciation un verre
à la main comme ça le mas est un peu
ridicule donc vous allez faire quoi une
fête non je n'ai pas organisé cette
année si on m'invite peut-être que je
vais y aller
j'en sais rien mais je suis sûr qu'il va
pas respecter également oui un malabar
non mais je pense que moi je pense que
les gens respectent les gestes barrières
les mesures de confinement à l'extérieur
mais dit qu'ils sont chez eux c'est une
utopie de fer avec la joie d'acteurs
quoi je suis pas je ferai une fête jour
ça va l'utopie de voeux quand on sait
pas si on va faire une fête à 15 jours
de l'événement
c'est une utopie de croire que les gens
portent les mâles le masque chez eux
dans n'est qu'un masque font l'amour
désolé mais j'ai envie de redonner la
pression ça va faire un an qui sont
confinés et ce qui est pas bien c'est ya
quinze jours dans l'allocution on a
sous-entendu que noël et le nouvel an ce
serait des sas de décompression et qu'on
pourra peut faire la fête les simples et
très rapidement moi je viens de passer
pour des raisons personnelles une
semaine dans un hôpital je peux vous
dire qu'ils sont débordés cerveau dit
que si un moment donné vous retrouver un
peu de respect pour les soignants pour
les mêmes et pour tous les gens qui sont
mères dauphins ctsp gascon en direct oui
à 23% même nom a soif et c'est marrant